Just before we get started with today's video,
I do want to see that it's brought to you by another channel that I host called
highlight history. It's a channel all about history, no shock there.
Recent topics include whether George Washington's doctors killed him.
They kind of did the man who stole the crown jewels and got away with it and
much more. Please do check it out through the link in the description below.
If you like, what you see, please do subscribe and let's get into today's video.
It's all worried about successful pirates,
something we've done quite a bit on this channel.
You may come to images of some rugged bidded European bloke,
a captain in commands of a handful of ships and a few hundred men.
He may have stolen a few hundred thousand Spanish dollars and may exert control
over a sea routes between I don't know, Yucatan and Cuba, and that's not bad,
but that's definitely naughty yet.
That's because arguably the most successful pirate in history was a Chinese
Admiral in charge of a vast fleet of hundreds of vessels mans by
70,000 men at its peak.
This virus had total control over a huge coastal area,
humiliating the Navy's of at least three major powers.
And this pirates was a sheep.
She was known as [inaudible] or Chiang Shao.
She was a master of diplomacy of trade and of Naval strategy.
She was the undisputed pirate queen of the South China sea.
[Inaudible].
I'd love to give you some details about the birth and early life for today's
protagonist,
but the truth is this origins were so humble and obscure that we don't even
know her exact date and place of birth sometime around 1771,
somewhere in Southern China, we are not even certain about her real name,
official records and histories refer to her by the names Chiang South Chiang's
wife or Chang. She Chang's widow.
So we can only imagine that the unnamed little girl was born to a family of poor
farmers or fishermen, somewhere along the coast of Canton province.
We can only presume that she fought her way through disease and starvation,
fending off infant deaths and slowly reaching adults while she grows up.
I will give you some historical context, which will prove key to our story.
In the late 18th century,
China was a United and powerful state sums of the rule of Ambra.
She had long succeeded by JIA Ching in 1796,
both emperors belonged to the stable and powerful Ching dynasty and had
succeeded in expanding China's territories and riches. However,
they both had failed at modernizing the empire to keep up with a massive
population spout to over-simplify.
Many farmers were left with too little arable land to sustain themselves,
leading them to seek other profitable trades and not necessarily on the right
side of the law. At the same time,
the Chinese civil service did not expand in proportions of the population.
Hence local government duties fell into the hands of local leaders whose
allegiances were to their localities and families rather than to the state.
This situation created perfect set of conditions for the rise of local warlords
and rebellious factions, such as the white Lotus,
struggling to maintain its own lot.
The Chinese military was significantly weakened and depleted of resources
leading to the emergence of even more regional warlords among them,
especially in the Southern province of quantum.
One could find powerful pirate Lords infesting the waters of the South
China sea in the 1790s, the Southern pirates were on the rise.
Thanks to rich patronage provided by Vietnam there in 1792,
then UN brothers that a successful bid for power. The tapes on rebellion,
the youngest brother had become Vietnamese emperor,
Chiang trunk to feeding the rival lead dynasty.
After the rebellion quadroon had lost most of its Navy.
So he took to hiring Chinese pirates as privateers.
A typical Chinese privateer could afford a fleet of several dozen junks
mountains by hundreds of Seders among these disparate gangs.
One emerged as the most powerful the fleet commanders by Chang E a man of
ambition who sought to unify and merge the major pirate fleets and do one single
dominant force.
Now we can go back to our protagonist by 1801.
She was in her late teens or early twenties as expected.
Widespread poverty had forced her into a disreputable trade prostitution.
She pedaled her trade aboard one of several fluting brothels in Kansas on these
refined boots of pleasure.
Patrons could enjoy a meal and a concert before moving on to the main
entertainment. If you like,
which apparently was made even more pleasurable by the gentle rocking and
rolling of the vessels.
She was renowned as one of the most beautiful girls on the floating palaces
admired for her looks as well as our charming and intelligent personality.
These were qualities which did not go unnoticed to pirate Lords Chang E
according to some versions of the story.
Jenny was so smitten with the girl's beauty,
grace and intellects that he courted her for weeks before proposing to her.
According to other versions,
the pirate Lord was initially motivated by pure lust.
You had the girl kidnapped and brought onto his ship just to have all for
himself, whatever origin story you prefer.
The next chapter is agreed upon the girl happily and willingly became Chang ESL,
the wife of Cheney butts on one condition.
She was not going to be relegated to the shore,
playing the role of the worried wife,
waiting for the adventurous husband to come home or even worse.
She was not going to be relegated to the bed chamber. No,
she wanted to take pots in Chinese strategic decisions,
lead the fleet at his side,
sharing both the risks and the rewards of piracy and a decision on common at
that time. And in that line of work,
Jenny accepted and made Mrs. Jang privy to his ambitions,
unifying the Southern Chinese pirates before achieving that goal,
that a couple of found time to enlarge their family and a rather unconventional
way sometime in 1801, Shang his pirates.
It captured the 15 year old son of a fishermen Chiang pal.
Jenny personally introduced him to a life of piracy by taking him as his lover.
This isn't a particular surprise as homosexual and bisexual relationships were
common amongst sea rovers of all ages and latitudes.
The boy showed promise and the Chang's gave him command of a junk Chen.
He even adopted the teenage captain. This was no ordinary adoption though,
which was just illegal apply to ensure inheritance rights for his protege.
As Chang Powell grew older,
it appears that Mrs. Chang was also involved in the relationship making it one
of those affairs that the French golden Menasha trois. Now add to the mix.
The fact that the Changs were formerly Chiang pals parents. And well,
let's just say that if Dr. Freud had been born several decades earlier,
had relocated to China and opened a floating clinic in cans on well,
he would have made a fortune,
but the happy family has other concerns in mind in July of 1802,
an occasion to unify the Southern pirates had finally materialized the taste on
forces in Vietnam had been defeated,
meaning the privateers had lost their primary employer.
The Chang's seize the day and establish their own leadership by reorganizing the
directionless pirates North of the Sino Vietnamese border in the Quantong
province,
they successfully organized a conglomerate of small gangs into six large fleets
under the red, black, white, green, blue, and yellow flags by 1804,
the six fleets were in perfect running order.
The red fleet was the most powerful one,
boasting 300 ships and 40,000 men altogether.
The Alliance forces numbered 400 vessels and 70,000 men.
This was not a gang of pirates anymore. It wasn't even a crime syndicate.
This was a Navy capable of holding its own against any sovereign
nation. Chiang might have appeared as the charismatic leader with the hands-on
experience and practical resume,
but the true strategic genius behind the lack of screen was
Chinese Sao.
She had showed the leadership of each fleet was in the hands of trusted
subordinates.
They had some limited degree of autonomy over the running of their fleet,
but were tied by personal law,
familial obligations to Chang E ensuring ultimate loyalty.
Mr. And Mrs. Chang's fleet was so successful that within a year,
the Imperial authorities weren't able to cope with the pirate threat.
The sea rovers upon Tang indirectly caused the downfall of the provincial
commander in chief. They directly killed his leading military commander,
general hung known as the old tiger the success. However,
glorious was short-lived. The husbands and wife team was doomed to fall apart.
Soon after.
[Inaudible].
In 1907, the undefeated Admiral Chang died suddenly,
probably in a storm off the coast of Vietnam.
His wife would come to be known as Chang.
She Chang's widow tradition dictated that she retired to a chest widowhood,
a quiet life,
maybe tending to Yardbirds in the garden or drinking tea on the seashore,
all this while perhaps admiring from afar,
the spectacle of an Imperial ship being blown up by the cannon fire of a pirate
junk, but Chang, she wouldn't hear any of this.
Her ideal retirements was never to have one in the first place.
The crafty pirate queen moved immediately to establish a position as the new
Admiral of the combined fleets. First of all,
she secured the support of her late.
Husband's two most powerful chief Dan's Chang and Pang and Chang power yang.
Then she appointed Chang pow,
her adopted son as leader of the most powerful red fleet and to cement their
Alliance. She had no qualms and ends during an open monogamous, sexual,
and dramatic relationship with him. So yes,
she married her adoptive son with strategic and diplomatic skills or widowed
manage to retain the services of the leaders of the multi-colored fleets.
They all agreed that by working together as they would be more effective,
perhaps most importantly,
they agreed to work together under Chiang Shi and Chang pow Jang she's next move
was to further consolidate her power.
She did so by establishing a strict code of rules and punishments to maintain
discipline and, and effective chain of command in a sprawling.
Our motto here are some of the laws of widow Chang. Well,
one orders should follow a strict top-down chain of commands. Yeah.
If as a lowly pirate,
you disobeyed orders from a superior or gave orders of your own,
your head would be chopped off on the spot. Number two,
any rate or business transaction had to be vetted by Chang sheet backed by the
might of the red fleet. She control the activities of every single junk.
After a successful rate at sea,
the loot was to be supervised by an accountant Chang.
She allowed the crew to keep 20% of that booty Airbus.
The rest had to be accumulated into a public funds. The Congress young,
if you pilfered from that funds. Well, yeah, your head would get chopped off.
Number three, women captured during raids should suffer no harm.
They were too profitable. Well, good looking captives.
At least they were to be sold into prostitution or slavery.
Not so good looking girls when I'm lucky enough to be freed almost immediately.
But what if a pirate raped one of the VMR prisoners? Well,
they would have his head chopped off.
And if the pirate queen had consensual sex with a prisoner, well,
they both get their heads chopped off.
That was the way I was at that punishment though.
A pirate could choose to take a captive as his concubine or wife bus if he did.
So he was obliged to remain faithful to her for life. If he didn't sweat,
he'd get his head chopped off. And number four don't harm the villages.
At least not the airline ones, Chang.
She had organized a network of coastal villages as supply basis for our fleet.
If you stole from those villages, of course,
your body would be severed from your head in a Swift cutting motion.
Finally, if you deserted all ENS a while, your ears would be,
cause often you would be paraded in front of your scenario. And in cremates,
if these laws were melting off Jang G and Jang bough also devised another
scheme, do you control their subordinates?
The quandong pirates were very religious and always besieged their gods before
going out for an expedition to facilitate that pres John bow ordered for a
magnificent 10 bolt to be built on one of the ships before major actions,
Chang bow,
and his lieutenants met at the temple to pray burn incense and confer with the
priest seeking divine approval for their plans. Miraculously,
the God seemed to always agree with Chiang Xi and Chang pals battle plans. Well,
the reason was quite easy to spot the two admirals simply met with the priests
beforehand,
exposed their and ensure that they would get divine backing during the public
ceremonies.
Now you may rule over 70,000 hardens men by the cover use of smoke and mirrors
and by the ruthless wielding of the stick,
but you also need to dangle the carrot Jang.
She knew this very well and she realized that to keep them in rich fat and
happy. The Newt stolen at sea may not be enough.
Chang. She followed.
Passing common. So many successful criminal organizations in history is that,
is she branched out into a legitimate business enterprise in her case,
it was the salt trade.
One of the most profitable in the contact area between 1807 and 1810,
the Chinese government employed a total of 270 junks collecting souls from the
Salters at TN PI and hauling it to Kansan Chang.
She had deployed two squadrons along the routes,
the first Indian pie itself and to the other on the fortress islands of now
ciao. One of the favorite hideouts from there,
the pirate junks relentlessly assaulted the Imperial soul ships capturing both
the vessels in the cargo.
Eventually the empire retains control over just four of them. Merchant ships,
Chang she's genius stroke was not to contend herself with selling the stolen
salt.
She goes into the business by forcing the captured cruise to continue hauling
salt on her terms, seeding a large part of the profits.
The widows are mater had established total arms control over the salt trade
routes.
And the South China sea one could say that she had established a monopoly of
violence over the area.
This is a term which was later coined to describe the activities of the Sicilian
mafia decades later, but it does fit perfectly here. It was a simple reality.
The pirates were the only ones who could decide if somebody would be harmed on
it,
unable to seek protection from the Basset Chinese Imperial Navy merchants in the
South,
China sea found it less risky and less costly to simply pay protection money to
Chang. She buying themselves safe passage on those otherwise treacherous routes.
This practice was applied to all sorts of trades, not just sold since by 1809.
It extended to the coastal villages, especially those on the Pearl river Delta.
As I said, protection, money is something you normally associate with the mafia,
but Chang, she was no Dawn for Nucci.
She had no time to stroll around small businesses, pocketing envelopes of cash.
She had ambition as an entrepreneurial mind.
She had set up financial offices in every major town on the coast,
especially Kansan and Macau.
Their agents collected fees from fishermen and traders,
selling them official documents, exempting them from pirates attacks.
The agents then reinvested the cash they collected into buying weapons and
ammunition for the fleet. It was indeed a vicious nautical and bar,
but it was certainly one that ran like clockwork to maintain a monopoly of
violence Chang. She could even rely on a sophisticated intelligence network.
Initially farmers,
fishermen and other coast dwellers were eager to cooperate with the pirate fleet
selling information on the whereabouts of enticing prey or enemy ships later on
Shang secured the cooperation of bandit gang secret societies,
even corrupt state officials,
ultimately the supply chain and intelligence service created by Chang.
She fed into the real muscle behind the power, the military prowess of a fleet.
She organized the larger fleets into powerful squadrons,
which attacked in cohesive formations, resembling floating fortresses,
native hastily, armed junks, Jang pals, personal squadron, for example,
consisted of 36 vessels mans by 1,422 men
operating more than 200 cannons.
The Imperial Navy was no match for such a force.
And there are accounts of admirals in Kwon Tung sabotaging their own ships to
avoid a confrontation with Chiang sheep.
Dan bruh tried to deploy forces from other provinces, but to no avail in 1808.
For example,
the military commander in chief of check gang province was dispatched to him,
telling him in an effort to protect Kansan with 135 ships and deal with the
pirates once. And for all it didn't work.
The Czech young general was killed in battle. And within six months,
the red fleet had destroyed 63 of the Imperial junks with little opposition at
sea Chang sheet moved to attack coastal forts and garrisons.
A favorite tactic was to engage the positions from a fall by having one of our
large squadrons deliver devastating barrage of cannon fire.
While the Garrison's artillery was on the defensive,
they failed to notice smaller junks carrying a landing party.
The amphibious force then storms the walls,
engaging the borne down defenders in close quarters.
This is where the pirates excels. There are no confirms accounts of Chang.
She taking part in the fighting, but it is realistic to expect that she did not.
As the overall leader, uh,
strategic skills were far too valuable for her to risk death in a skirmish.
There are however,
several accounts of pirate wives fighting fiercely alongside the first lines or
description of one of the few pirates defeats that Lao one Shan mentions a
pirate wife.
You killed or wounded several soldiers arms with a couple in each hands.
Formidable women also fought on the other side and accounting.
The battle between Chang bow and village militia features a formidable lady
kicking pirate booty side-by-side next to a martial arts master husband Wei Tang
ciao, overall display, fierce resistance, and the old defeat.
Nobody in Quantong proved to be a match for the fleet of many colors.
With few domestic enemies left to pray on Jang.
She started then looking outwards.
[Inaudible].
She's fleet escalated the attacks against ships belonging to foreign powers,
including Simon Portugal, the United States and the East India company.
In a matter of days in September of 1809 Chang,
she and Chang pow attacked a five American schooners in Macau captured the break
belongings to the Portuguese governor in the team or colony and ransoms and
entire tribute mission coming from Siam.
These were by no means the first attacks against Western shipping. In fact,
taxed by the Changs had been a nuisance and the British East India company in
Portugal for more than a decade and AVS had offered to help in the fight against
piracy, but the Imperial court had always refused mainly out of national pride.
Finally, in the very same September, 1809,
the emperor agreed to negotiate with the Westerners.
The Chinese Navy secured help from six Portuguese men of war,
as well as from an East India company ship gradually more and more Western
vessels entered the fray, adding pressure on [inaudible] fleet.
It eventually fell into numerical and technological disadvantage,
the crafty widow Chang and her husband even tried to get the Portuguese to
switch sides. On the 26th of December,
the cheeky Chiang Powell sent a letter to the commander of the Portuguese fleets
of Macau asking for three or four of them, men of war,
Jang power reassured him that he was destined to topple the emperor.
Very soon after the victory,
he would have gifted two or three provinces to the Portuguese Admiral.
The pirate Lords did not succeed in his negotiations,
which were bad news for sheep by early 18,
10 Chang she's fleet was showing the first signs of implosion.
Then you enemies contributed to this for sure.
But the main reason was the internal dissent among the fleets Lords Chang.
She had a choice continue to fight against basically a half of the worlds or
complete the transition to legitimate activities.
The risk was to see her Naval empire crumbled to pieces.
So loyal sailors and soldiers dragged into chains or blown to pieces.
The other option was to seize an opportunity for negotiation and see how men off
to a wealthy career before it was too late.
She chose the latter option while she was still in a position of strength.
So we do offer it the Chinese empire.
Attempting deal.
The 21st 18,
10 Chang Sherry and Chang bow met with piling the governor general of the Leon
Kwong territory,
which encompassed Quantong and with Miguel Jose Arriaga era,
Portuguese official from the colony and Macau, the widow's proposal was simple.
She would dismantle a fleet and surrender most of our ships and weapons in
exchange.
She demanded a total pardon for herself and all of the pirates as well as
official appointments for Chang Pau and other leaders.
The final condition was for her and Chang pal to retain a small force of 80
junks and 5,000 sailors.
Their initial negotiations stalled when piling refused the Chang bow retained to
such a sizable squadron,
no progress was made until April of 1810 on the aides Chang.
She resisted her advisor's concerns and bravely walked into pilings residence
escorted only by the wives and children of some of our captains.
The stubborn widow would not have no for an answer.
If piling wanted to get rid of the nightmare, that was her fleet.
He had to concede those 80 junks to Chang pal,
and she even raised her demands further asking for 40 extra junks for the salt
trade piling yielded. Two days later, he met with Chang,
she and her staff at a pagoda in Macau where they signed the final deal immunity
for all 120 junks,
Chang bow and official appointments in the military and civilian administration
for subordinate leaders,
Jane power himself received a commission as a Lieutenant Colonel in the Imperial
army receiving a promotion to Colonel. Soon after Jang,
she was now considered to be the respectable wife of a young rising star within
the military and as such,
she would be addressed with the honorific title of Ming Sal 12 years later in
1822,
Chang Powell died perhaps during a storm like his adopted father after having
enjoyed more than a decade of quiet life at the expenses of the state are twice
widowed,
protagonist settled back in Kansan with the two children she had from Chiang
pal. Her last years of life were largely common prosperous.
The ones pirate queen invested in the soul trait and opens gambling
establishments in Kansan and Macau. Ironically,
the one in Kansan also doubled as a brothel from her position of wealth.
She observed how the power of the Chinese embar steadily declined in the 19th
century, bullied by Western powers.
It appears that around 1839 at the onset of the first opium war against the
British, she may have been consulted by the current governor on matters of Naval
strategy. By the second year of war in 1840,
the women known as the widow Chang had died peacefully in her sleep at the
height of our power Chang.
She was a pirate queen who oversaw gambling and prostitution.
She was in every sense of the word, a crime boss,
but it is impossible not to admire how she reversed traditional gender roles and
broke through a traditionally restricted female social mobility.
She built her own career,
her own ladder to success first by acting as the power behind Chang E and then
by stepping into the power vacuum and assuming command.
And then finally by negotiating the masterpiece of a deal,
which ensured a quiet gilded life for her and our cohorts.
And so we leave the last one.
Do you Chang, she lost a criminal or wrong.
So I really hope you enjoyed that video. If you did,
please do hit that thumbs up button below. Don't forget to subscribe. Also.
I've got a brand new channel called side projects,
which covers a whole lot of interesting stuff. I'll link to that channel below.
Please do check it out if you feel like it. And thank you for watching.